kelly it's so good to see you my darling
and i love your hair thank you i mean
i'm playing around with some new looks
i can never fully commit to anything
because i was just saying before
that if i did the permanent extensions
it takes
12 to 15 hours to do my full head
so i know that i would sit there for it
and then like three days later i'd be
like get this out
so i'm just doing the clippings but now
seeing how i like it
and playing around a bit i love it so
first things first how
are you doing spiritually so much better
than i was
i have a little bump in the road a
little slip
with uh my not so good friend alcohol
and now we're back to
getting it together i uh everything in
my life was going so great
that my mind told me i was normal and
that i could drink normally
and that i could have fun like that and
i'm not normal in that way i never will
be and
it was just a bit of a you know a
wake-up call real quick
needed the reality check i guess so
there was no trigger it's just
it was just a moment in your life it
just happened that's the worst part
about addiction is you never know
when it's gonna what what's gonna tell i
was literally sat there
and i saw these people by a pool and i
was like oh yeah i can do that
and i ordered a glass of wine wow
and i just had that one glass of wine i
was like yeah see
cut to one week later she's disgusting
and a hot mess covered in like food and
drunk
and i'm like no this is not me i am not
doing this
and it actually was um
the way that i was i was talking to the
guy that i
date now and he just he didn't say
anything
he just looked at me and i was like
i feel how that look looks like i felt
that
like noted instead yeah we're fixing
this problem
like not
you figured it out so quickly which is
so amazing and the fact that you
actually
share it on instagram story i mean
something so personal i
i have to say thank you because that's
going to help so many people who are
following your journey i mean
that's how did it feel yeah how did it
feel for you to do that
oh shameful
it really did the truth is like i never
asked to be a role model
i don't consider myself a role model but
because i am in the public eye
and i do have these issues and i am open
about it people
do look to me so i never want to be one
of those people that
lies about where i'm at
what i'm doing because then that leads
people just to try and catch you all the
time look what she's doing look what
that's doing
and also i need to hold myself
accountable that's the kind of person
i am when i have done something wrong i
will be the first person to be like yeah
i did this
working on it let's fix this fix this
sort this out like i am
somebody who is so solution based i
don't want to sit here and be a part of
the problem i only ever want to be a
part of the solution
and so i sit there and i'm like okay and
i can be
so self-victimizing and for a
full solid like week i was like i'm a
victim this is
everybody else's fault it's not it's my
fault
it's my choices it's my decisions and
i um and it's my life and you know the
thing is
i thought that everybody was gonna be
like can't believe you did that
what are you thinking it wasn't the case
it i got so much love and support
and so many people reaching out that i
was like
okay i don't have to shave the spiral i
can pick myself up because
i do know the tools i do have the skills
and if i can share my experience
experience strength and hope with
anybody else to help them move forward
in whatever they're going through
because let's face it
everything we knew in recovery got
ripped away from us this year
like can't go to meetings can't have
fellowship you can't
you know see people and i'm the kind of
alcoholic that i need to be in that i
need to be around that i need to be
around
fellow alcoholics who are going through
what i'm going through to help me
move forward like in it and so that's
why i
came clean and it's also so that
my vindictive and manipulative mind
couldn't be like well no one knows i can
just keep going
right right because i could have kept
going and not said anything and nobody
would have known
not one person well except for people
who were there but
you know what i mean yeah and that says
a lot like you've grown as a person
and the fact they say i've always
promised you that i'll always be honest
with you and that really hit me hard
because
the way we use social media the way you
use social media
the way you said like people gave you
these positive reactions to it
i mean for you how does that feel is
that
helping you in any way for your own
spirit oh
oh my god it like i was stuck there like
crying all day and i'm not just talking
about hundreds i'm talking about
thousands of people message me
like crying my eyes are reading them
because they were all so nice and then
hearing other people's stories because
they would like they weren't just short
messages they were long
like like filling up to where they had
to keep sending me a message
to because there was no more space
and it you know hearing reading other
people's stories and
what they're going through that and
sharing
it it helps you it helps it gives you
encouragement like they're doing it i'm
doing it
we can do this you know and so what is
self-care for you
coming out of this what are you doing to
take care of yourself um
for me like i was like okay i i'm not
using any of my tools i have stopped
meditating so i have joined
a cognitive um training
course where there is gonna teach me how
to retrain my thoughts
and i'm gonna do that for a month and
just kind of
put myself back on track and your little
pups they're taking care of you
right it's great because
i did it right before work got too crazy
and
i can kind of navigate this but i also
have work to keep me busy and
it's you know it's just a bump in the
road this is this is part of my journey
this is part of
i guess let's just say for lack of a
better term god's plan
so i just have to
it's it my biggest problem is my
self-will
as soon as i put that in front of
anything uh that's when everything comes
everywhere like i'm done you're amazing
and on top of that we're not drinking
we're not we're back on track we're not
drinking you're doing a podcast now
that's gonna be able to
get people entertained you're gonna
bring a lot to this podcast
tell me how the concept came together
and why you want to do it okay so
so jeff and i have worked together for
20 years
and we we did beaches mad house
we've also put on comedy shows we did
vegas like all sorts of stuff we've done
together
and i'm always the creative director and
come in and help put the show together
and he's the front man of it and
we spent so much time together during
quarantine
that because he lived alone and i lived
alone so we both were like okay let's
just go walking every day and we both
lost
more weight we got healthy we turned it
into like we both like
anybody would have thought we were
insane we had like this crazy routine to
everything because him and i both
one of our isms is we have ocd really
bad
and the there were days where like
i literally couldn't beat my room
because everything had to be a certain
way
and if i felt like it was too dirty i
couldn't leave and it was
a thing that that he was going through
too and now we sit back and we're
laughing about like
the stuff that we went through and
people like you guys do
a podcast you're so funny because they
would see us walking down the street
and i'd be like jeff stay stay like 10
feet away from me and he's like i've not
been anywhere i'm like i don't know
like if anybody was walking their dog
past us or sprayed them with lifestyle
and everybody was just like looking like
why don't you guys do a podcast because
everybody is sort of doing one
right and so we did one just to test her
and everyone went wild for it and within
like two days we had an offer to do
from broadcast one and the deal went
through
so quickly and now we're like oh i guess
we do a podcast now
that's crazy and so what can we expect
there's going to be celebrities on it or
your friends going to be a fam
first of all one of the things is just
being unapologetically yourself
that's a huge message for us and one of
the other messages what you call freaks
we call family so
if you're one of the unwanted or the
untouchables in this world that
or you think that there's nowhere where
you belong with us and
that's the messaging that we're trying
to get across but also you know we're
going to have
celebrity guests and then people from
our family coming in
like when i say family i mean our
extended family like our friends and
but it's more just like talking about
like our weight loss journeys and
we have to go back and record the first
episode because of my relapse
it's like we're gonna do the first one
on relapse prevention
and um we're bringing on mike bear who
is an incredible sober coach and sober
companion and helps so many yeah
and he's amazing and and just kind of
be dead honest about everything that's
going on and everything that we know
when we don't know
and it's just a safe place to have fun
it's gonna say you talked about your
health journey too
and i'm really curious because i love
talking about health journey i i'm on a
kick too right now
are you gonna be talking about the whole
experience of what you've gone through
from
your ups and downs detail the surgery
what we went through
tips um we're just jeff and i are in the
process of also
um starting an organization where
we pay for people to get the surgery
they can't afford it
so it because it's so life-changing and
it isn't always covered by insurance and
once you get that it's not it's not a
quick fix
and it isn't easy but it's a gentle
nudge in the right direction and a tool
that can push you
to get your goal if you think that you
can just do this surgery
and you're going to lose weight you're
wrong it's not how it works
at all like you have to commit how kelly
is it for you to look in the mirror now
fun like my body's changing so much
and like i keep like like i'm so
critical of myself and i always like
lift up my shirt and be like well that's
wobbly
need to move this around but it's it
i'm getting to learn my body again and i
never realized how small i
actually am like i share clothes with my
nine-year-old niece that's crazy
she's almost as tall as me now and i'm
like
maybe i actually was quite a small
person that was just really packed in
there you know
but it's great so so you're happy i am
happy
and yeah each day is exciting and
i used to be the girl that was like what
do i have to do today
and now i'm the girl that's like what do
i get to do today and
it's it's all about changing your
outlook and i'm not going to sit here
and pretend like every day is like this
it's not
yeah yesterday i couldn't get out of bed
and i don't even know why
right you know what i'm saying yeah
i feel you girl i feel you yeah i don't
even know why i was like
okay i'll just stay here and i watch
seoul and disney movies on tv to try and
make myself feel better
there you go i watch let it go frozen i
i totally get you you know it's
it's amazing because looking at you and
talking to you right now i mean we
watched you grow up we watched your ups
and downs we saw everything you're good
at
everything for everything for
everything everything but my vagina at
this point
so oh girl but has that affected you
being in the public eye for
so long does it affect you in a way
longer than i haven't at this point
since i was eight yeah
30 37 this year and
it's interesting to see like everyone
was
like you're 15 minutes i'm like was a
long 15 minutes
like right what kind of watch are you
using but
it's it's great it's fun i love
seeing all the changes and being a part
of this
industry i used to hate it yeah but
it's the only thing i'm good at you know
i used to try and like do anything not
to be a part of
the industry in this world but now i
embrace it and i love it it's made me
who i am
and it's exciting i get to meet
so many incredible people and have so
many incredible experiences
and it's i don't take it for granted
anymore
i love it and it's part of great yeah
you're 37 you said
right okay when you hit your 40s you
just like
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah you're getting to that age where
you just you have this wisdom and you
just you just
turn around it's all about feeling good
it's weird like i don't look my age i
know that and
people still think i'm like 15 which is
so weird
so weird like when people who are
younger than me come up and like pat me
on my
like what are you doing like that oh bad
you know god
yeah so
what is your ultimate joy my ultimate
joy
first of all my dogs i'm like i am i'm
an animal person like
my brother makes so much fun of me but
my my ultimate joy
is getting to be myself
and i it took me a while i don't
necessarily
like myself every day but at least i get
to be myself
i don't have to walk around in a costume
and i did that for so long so long and
now it's taking care of yourself right
that's what it's all about
it truly is that i could i get to work
with my best friends and
i've got three shows four shows in
pre-production
and everything is kind of coming full
circle but i date an incredible man
and now i'm just like
fixing the last broken pieces it's clear
there's something still broken because i
drank
it now you know we'll figure it out i
love that and i love the fact that
you're working on a project with adam
lambert i saw those shots that you guys
were working together i just
absolutely love him and adore him so
it's so great to see you guys working
together
he's great i absolutely love
every second of every day that i ever
get to spend with him
he's so much fun and like oh he's the
best
i love that and how is danny life going
is it going well
very well it's very exciting getting to
know somebody
and being in a healthy relationship
which is something i'm not used to
i know there you go i'm not used to that
i always want to go and push a few
buttons and wind them up and he's like
stop doing that like okay
can i just say one thing you have the
most beautiful teeth i've ever seen
thank you you really do thank you very
much i just got on you
staring at you please be happy
so nice
[Laughter]
you just made my day here i'm i'm so
happy right now
wash my hair now my goodness i
absolutely adore you
you are just amazing and i could see a
lot of positive energy from you and
you're in a good place and i'm just so
happy for you and congratulations on all
your success
and i know we're going to see so much
from you so really appreciate it
thank you so much thank you everybody
bye thank you
you